hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast
[Music]
i'm just checking in on you
i'm just checking in on you
oh billy [ __ ] thespian
doing his acting gig this month
memorizing his lines
saying the stuff he memorized standing
on a piece of tape
i'm actually having a great time
um
i'm having a great time but my world
is really small as i mentioned so let's
get let's get down to it here's one for
[ __ ] old people
this is something probably everybody in
australia already knows
all right
if you have a beet salad
for dinner
the next morning you're gonna think you
have blood in your urine
and as you go into the bathroom you're
gonna be like what the [ __ ] is that
and you're gonna be like wait am i dying
am i dying
oh [ __ ] i'm dying
and by the end of it you're like well
you know i had a good run
i had a good mommy what am i special
steve mcqueen died at 50. who the [ __ ]
am i right i'm 53 gonna be 54. i got an
extra [ __ ]
four years off of that guy
and then you're like oh wait a second
wait a minute i had a beet salad last
night
oh that's what it is and then you don't
go to the doctor
and then the next day you have another
one and the same thing happens again and
you're just like
what if
i am eating beet salad at the exact
moment i got bladder cancer
well what are the odds of that so then
you [ __ ] google search it right
and next thing you know
anything you're looking at on youtube
there's a bunch of colostomy bags and
then in the advertising it's just like
will you stop spying on me
all right my my beat red p
is my business
not yours okay
do you know next year apple is gonna
come out with their own colostomy bag
it's supposed to be unfucking believable
um well
there you go that's all i got going on
in my life oh my god oh let me hold my
wife oh let me tell you let me tell we
had sweet a couple of dumb fights this
week
right so i had like super early calls
where i had to get up and like set the
alarm at like 4 40 in the morning
so the first day you know i'm sleeping
next to her and it goes
whatever the [ __ ] it does
it's an old school alarm but whatever
that's what it sounds like right it
literally sounds like a duck is telling
the worst story ever right next to your
[ __ ] ear right
just starting off on ten
it's like dude build the story
you know start low
and take me somewhere like quack
quack quack quack quack
quack
quack
okay
and crack that great yeah that's how you
do it you don't just ah
you come right out of the [ __ ] gate
hey you wouldn't believe what [ __ ]
happened to me
goddamn ducks with their [ __ ] stupid
stories there so
um
anyway
i [ __ ] uh
i wake up you know after a rough night
because i'm fighting off this cold
because both of my kids you know have
colds
you know so i'm going to bed you know
i'm taking nyquil
okay you take nyquil you go to bed you
have like those cold medicine dreams you
know where you wake up in the morning
you're like did i commit a crime last
night or was that like
no no that didn't happen
that didn't happen that i beat the
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of that guy at the gym
i had a dream last night i beat the [ __ ]
out of this like it was this weird thing
where i was gonna use the bench
not for benching to do tricep work which
is a really that's a [ __ ] no-no at
the gym
you know what i mean
because everybody goes and does their
chest
everybody wants to work on their
chesticles so the ladies can be like oh
my god you're so are you he-man
i thought you were a he-man
um
yeah and then you don't do any back
exercises and your [ __ ] shoulders
come forward and then you fight rotator
cuff issues like i am for the last
[ __ ] goddamn forever right
but i'll do it if there's nobody else in
the gym and there's another like bench
station available but in this dream i
just went over and i did it and as i did
it this other [ __ ] guy wanted to use
the bench so i'm sitting there and he
walks up to me and just ever so gently
he slapped me in the face twice the
first time i'm like do i know this guy
and then he did it again and i'm like
what the [ __ ]
and then for whatever reason he was on
that that you know that station that um
you [ __ ]
you stand up on and then your forearms
support you as you take your feet off
the where you have your feet and then
you lift your legs up and you do ab work
he got on one of those and i just went
up and i just grabbed him by his [ __ ]
throat
and i started slapping him and i was
just screaming you know [ __ ] slap me
you know this is this is because i'm
telling you
nyquil is [ __ ]
amazing
and then it's also like you know you're
gonna have some really weird violent at
least i do i have like violent dreams
and i commit crimes and i assault people
i don't know what's going on
so i had those dreams and then i wake up
and i had after having a beach salad and
then i think i'm dying
um
so whatever that's what the [ __ ] i'm
going through right so anyway so my
[ __ ] alarm
[ __ ] goes off
and my wife's like oh what oh my god
it's jesus pillows right and she [ __ ]
goes back to sleep
so anyway and i go to work
right
like the [ __ ] man i am
i trudge out the door with my script
time to make the donuts right i go out
[ __ ] door
and i go down to crafty
she [ __ ] gets around it's crafty
right i get my little breakfast
on set as they say out here on location
and i get a text
about three hours later
and my wife she says hey can you do me a
favor if you have another early call
time
tomorrow
you know
can you can you sleep downstairs or
whatever
or sleep out you know
in in my room above the garage can you
sleep out there that's what she wanted
me to do right
so i come home
you know and she sent that laughing
emojis
she tried she was trying
to be nice
to a nyquil man with beet juice in his
urine right
so i come home right and she goes do you
have another early call tomorrow
you know not how was your day
not oh there's my man who went out and
earned some money so we can all eat
cornflakes tomorrow morning that's not
what she said
it's not what she said at all she said
do you have
another early call time tomorrow and i
said yes i do she goes can you sleep
above the garage and i said i'm not
sleeping there because what if this is
the night some [ __ ] guy comes through
the front door and i'm out there
sleeping and god knows what happens to
you guys now that might have been the
night quilt talking but that was the
first
it's the first thing i thought of
so
i don't do that
and the next morning 4 40 in the morning
so i get up
and i can feel her anger in the dark i
can feel her anger so i go in trudging
in
you know
and i'm in the shower and when i'm in
the shower she comes walking in to use
the bathroom and she walks by with the
[ __ ] this look on her face
okay
like she's that guy in the league that
never gets a [ __ ] offensive foul
right she comes [ __ ] walking right by
and i was so [ __ ] mad i'm like i'm
thinking like i'm the [ __ ] good
enough for 440 to go [ __ ] work you're
gonna go back to sleep right
so i did what most adults does right as
she got out of my vision i gave her the
double finger from inside the [ __ ]
shower right this is this is what you do
when you're married
okay
and um
you know she was like mad at me
and i'm thinking like rather than me
just being like bill you know you're
leaving and then she has to take care of
two kids and you're waking her up at 4
40 in the morning rather than thinking
that i'm thinking like
you know i'm the guy getting up going
outside to go pretend to be something
i'm not
put a little respect right
so i [ __ ] leave
i go to work right to be or not to be
that is the question
okay could you do it this time
and not stress it is
could you stress the bee
yeah i got it all right
still roll it
to be
or not to be that is the question that
was the one
that was the one
right
so
i come home for work all right
now she's two days getting woken up at 4
40.
all right and i also got up at 4 40. so
tensions are rising
like russia ukraine within my marriage
this is like what's happening like
troops have been brought to the border
and by the way if i hear one more
[ __ ] [ __ ] here in america did you
see what they did it's oh my god it's
awful oh i can't you know i just i can't
what is wrong with them it's just like
are you gonna do anything about it
are you just gonna stand around and talk
about how awful it is
i just it is just it is heartbreaking it
is so hard did you see that new bakery
that they have opened up on la brea
um
anyway
so i [ __ ] uh
yeah so i do my day right
and i came home
and then
later on that now you know she's a
little [ __ ] grumpy right i'm a little
tired so you see what's gonna happen
okay you have a high pressure system
next to a low pressure so you know
what's gonna happen right
so she goes outside at one point towards
the end of the night
when i'm getting ready to go to bed and
she walks out and she leaves the front
door open wide open as we have the heat
cranked so i'm one of those dads where
i'm just like we got the heat on [ __ ]
close the doors that's how i was brought
up
what yeah geez whether you were you
brought up in a barn
i always loved that when my parents
would say that to me were you raised in
a barn it's like well why don't you
think back you raised me
i think pretty much we were in a
garrison colonial
um
so she leaves the door wide open so i
just go to like just not close it all
the way i'm leaving the door
a jar
and as i'm going to close it she's
outside going like i'm coming back in
i'm coming right back in don't close the
door i'm coming right back in do i
listen no
i'm like i don't give a [ __ ] the heat is
cranked and it's going outside
right so i just close it like that and
then you know she comes she was bringing
a kid seated you know all she had to do
was just shoulder the door a little bit
it would have swung wide open
so now she's not really mad about that
she's mad because she hasn't gotten the
right amount of sleep because my [ __ ]
thespian douchebag ass is [ __ ] waking
up at her up too at 4 40 in the morning
right
so
she just comes she's like why would you
do that
why would you close the door and i said
it's like i didn't close the door just i
just don't understand why you would do
that and then i was just like i was like
you know what
why would you give me a dirty look when
i'm the guy going out the [ __ ] door
making the money to make to earn money
for the cheerios
it's because i'm not talking about that
well i am
right had this big dumb
fight
where she of course immediately tried to
make up with me because she's more
mature than i am right
and i'm like i'm still mad right
and then the next day she texts me after
i got up after sleeping over the garage
another 4 40 in the morning
okay
going back off to work
two we are not to be that is the
question all
right she texts me about halfway through
the day
how's it going
right
that's not what she said she said how's
it going because she's a sweetheart
and i said well i love you again which
got a big laugh
via text and it was over just like that
okay and that's what happened to me
over the last couple of days as
everybody's hearts were breaking for
what's going on over in the ukraine as
they do absolutely
nothing
about it
as they look at that and don't see
themselves in it
drives me up
the [ __ ] wall did you see they bombed
this yeah that that's what invading a
country looks like
if you didn't live behind the media wall
you know that doesn't show that [ __ ]
when we do it but instead focuses on
stand-up comedians and the jokes that
they told in a [ __ ] strip mall
and people watch it like it's news
um sorry
i'm not getting off my [ __ ] little
liberal stump about this [ __ ] thing
until people stop telling me that their
hearts bridge you just see what happened
to the dolphins
oh my god my heart breaks
for those dolph you know so i was
talking to a surfer yesterday
before it became a quentin tarantino
pulp fiction song
um surf for rock music right i was
talking to him he's like you know
dolphins are kind of [ __ ] he didn't say
it like that but that's basically what
he was saying
and he was saying that the adolescent
ones uh
you know
they don't even there's nothing to like
when there's shark attacks and [ __ ] they
they it's jaws dude
there's the [ __ ] mayor going we're
not closing the beach and you're not
reporting on that because if you do
we're gonna lose a [ __ ] load of money
and all of these [ __ ] dum-dums
go to the beach and they go into that
water and they don't
you know
literally
i mean i'm trying to think of another
environment
that you go to where there's just things
that can eat you alive and you're that
close oh i know what it is it's called
the [ __ ] zoo
and if you notice when you go to the zoo
when you go to the [ __ ]
zoo they got all those things in cages
they have them down in pits and even
then they don't [ __ ] that doesn't
sometimes stop them
okay you've seen bears they can [ __ ]
open car doors they'll like open a
refrigerator and lean on it
looking for something to eat like this
is their [ __ ] joint right
i mean you really gotta watch
they're like toddlers like toddlers
watch you open a door and they're just
clocking everything is that how it goes
and they start trying with their little
[ __ ] cute hands
bears are the same way
all right
um but i remember hearing this story i
think was up in san francisco this guy
was teasing like a tiger or a lion i
think it was a tiger and he was [ __ ]
with this thing
and it was down in a pit and it got so
[ __ ] mad
it had so much adrenaline it jumped up
out of the [ __ ] pit
ran by a bunch of other people and went
right to this guy and [ __ ] mauled him
to death okay unless that's an urban
myth i looked it up
i think it was in the san francisco so
and so and that's a legitimate paper up
there
look it up let me know if that's true or
not
um
but yeah
those same [ __ ] you would never
go out into the wilderness or in the
jungle
with no [ __ ] weapon
all right all you dear urine guys proud
to be an american
i'm shooting my own food
when the dollar collapses i'm gonna
[ __ ] eat you
i'll shoot you in your torso get you
center mass
then take out mcginsoo and cut meat off
your ass
sorry that was a reference to the
japanese army in world war ii um
what the [ __ ] am i talking about yeah
you would never go out there with no
[ __ ] weapon
all right but people every goddamn day
do that when they go into the [ __ ]
ocean
and there's so many goddamn i just it
just [ __ ] blows my mind and
everybody's like dude you know what the
[ __ ] odds are you don't know what the
odds are
because every [ __ ] town has a mayor
like the guy in jaws
yelling at chief brody
notice whenever they say a shark attack
they always put rare very rare
[Music]
shark attack it's not rare
the only thing rare is the meat coming
off your [ __ ] body
unless you're like unless you're a
redhead you've been out in the sun too
long then you might be a medium rare
um
so this guy this surfer man
mahalo man
he [ __ ] told me
old freckles himself he told me that
they had this thing i think down in
florida
where these adolescent dolphins you know
these juvie dolphins that should have
been sent somewhere gotten their [ __ ]
dolphin mine rights that their job in
the world
is to [ __ ] study in the ocean so
someday they can support their family
working at sea world
they were grabbing swimmers and pulling
them down and drowning them and they
were sticking them in this cave and they
went down there and they found a bunch
of bones
from these people that they probably
just said was drownings
and the mayor was saying like i don't
know don't don't say it was a shark
attack and it was actually dolphins
dolphins everybody who we think
give a [ __ ] about us because there was a
show called flipper 50 years ago
on television
and you know you got to understand
that dolphins can't help you out
dolphins are like spider-man
it all depends on what suit they're
wearing that day okay if they had the
red and blue one
like two out of the three colors
on our flag out here in america
right they're the
the he's
they're the good spider-man they're the
good dolphin
but if they put on the suit of color
then they're the best and what message
does that send to the dolphin community
do you see that when spider-man wears
the black suit he actually becomes a bat
the suit takes over and he does cr i
know it breaks my heart i can't i just i
i can't
that's something a lot of white people
i've noticed can't you know that's the
thing they can't i can't i just can't
did you see that i can't
i [ __ ] can't
my heart breaks
like i couldn't stop thinking
of what i saw that happened yesterday
to the point when that man was handi
hanging up my new flat screen tv i
couldn't even he's like is it level it's
like i don't even know
he's like what's going on with you and
say don't you realize
that even though i'm standing in this
giant open floor plan with indoor
outdoor living that my heart is actually
breaking as i think about horrible
things
that are happening to other people just
know
when i get in my infinity pool why am i
acting like all white people have [ __ ]
like this
um
it's a lot of broke white people too
why am i just attacking white people
because it's fun
you know i tell you when i my heart
breaks
for the people facing them dirty
russians
and when i sit in my double wide i
earned it [ __ ]
what i said in my double wide tonight
and drinking a w root beer no
with a little bit of
nyquil in it that my heart breaks for
those
those people over there
um
well g bill when did you become so
perfect i don't know when i got an
acting gig
and i had to get up at 4 40 in the
morning
because right now i am a working actor
um
i don't it really has nothing to do with
people that saying their hearts break
that's good they're expressing that they
actually have empathy for other people
but then like what are you supposed to
do what in the [ __ ] do you do
you can't really do anything you try to
do something you get labeled a commie
you know if you're in russia and you try
to say hey man don't invade uh the
ukraine then they call you a capitalist
you can't win
and you know i blame i blame god because
he made us all
you know i blame him
i'm sick of the [ __ ]
accolades
nothing but [ __ ]
five-star [ __ ] reviews
on the religious channel
um
anyway
you know what one of the highlights of
my my not
my not you know doing what i was doing
yesterday i was riding
club soda kenny's out here he's on the
job right he was driving me back
um
to base camp and i saw this white
dodge 3500 four-wheel drive dually
and i just was looking at thing and i
was just like god damn it i wish i led a
life that justified owning that thing
[Music]
can't drive around on that
hey buddy what are you a horse you got a
bunch of horses you got a horse farm
no
well you got will you towing a boat
no i'm afraid of the water
you
well [ __ ] you got you
you're restoring cars or something you
gotta tow like over ten thousand pounds
you get a couple of them on there is
that what you got
no
well what is it
i just like the way it looks and sounds
[Music]
i have a lot of that in my life
now you like me
do you own some badass [ __ ] that you
really like but secretly know that when
you wear it or use it that you know
the makers of it weren't making it for
you
that they were making it for actually
truly badass people you're like me do
you own a guitar
but only can play a few chords
but like if slash had it he could
actually tour the world with it you know
well yeah that's a new subject what is
so what's the most badass thing that you
own that you know secretly in your heart
it wasn't made for you because you're
not that person you know
like maybe you saw i don't know
somebody in a movie wearing something
and you're like i'm gonna wear that
shirt
you know after i just watched him beat
up a whole bar bar room full of [ __ ]
knife-wielding lunatics
you know do you got a steven seagal ghee
you got one of those things
or maybe you're just a man with the
ponytail
you know
you bought yourself a dodge challenger
you know and you pull into some town
you've never been into and you get out
you think people are looking at you like
ooh
who's that stranger
is he wearing cowboy boots is he a
cowboy he owned cowboy boots
do you know cowboys you could go on some
cowboy boots right you don't own a cow
and you're a man at this point huh
i'll tell you one for you if you want to
talk about a lot of people that just
drive trucks for no good goddamn reason
um
texas
i've never seen so many [ __ ] pickup
trucks in my life i mean that's where i
i should go i should [ __ ] move there
i should move there
because i i mean i even think if i drove
a dually even they would be like now now
god damn it bill we all know
you live in a condo high-rise
in downtown dallas all right looking at
looking out over the american airlines
arena you got no business
owning that truck can i drive it
sometime
i got an idea what if we what if i got
an idea what if we drive it off road get
it all dirty like we work right like we
work with our hands and our backs for
our living and and then uh we put on
some dirty clothes and uh uh then we go
and we pull up
pull up to some place and everybody
thinks that we worked hard that day and
we really did
um
dallas and houston
um
just some of the most shiniest beautiful
pickup trucks i've ever seen in my life
that have never
other than rain
you know if you want to buy a used
pickup truck go to dallas or houston
there is zero miles
on that towing hitch
never been plowed
just driving to and from work you know
pulling you know
pulling into starbucks
oh by the way i finally gave in to
coffee
and it almost got its hooks into me it
almost got its hooks into me i had
um
i had a cappuccino
uh and it was the first cup of coffee i
ever drank the whole thing because i've
always had a few sips and i've just been
that's too bitter i don't like the [ __ ]
i love the smell
and every time i'd go to the airport and
see all these [ __ ] people lining up
like they're at the meth clinic
i just remember always thinking like
thank god i never i didn't i've done a
lot of dumb [ __ ] but i didn't get into
that dumb [ __ ] well
i was tired
you
know that [ __ ] after a couple of days
and i had a cappuccino
and i took that first sip and it was
kind of okay and by the third sip i'm
like
oh wait a minute
i think i get this
and i drank the whole [ __ ] thing
and then the next day
i had another early day and i [ __ ]
drank another one
and the second day it didn't taste bad
at all it tasted delicious
from the second it hit my lips like
frank the tank
when he did that funnel when he funnels
those beers in old school
right to the very end and i was like oh
my god
i get it
there had to be a reason these people
were standing in this line it has to be
that good
slash it's an addiction
um
and then
three days in a row
i fought it and i didn't get a cup of
coffee and now i don't give a [ __ ]
anymore
because i was just like i can't do this
i did this with booze i did this with
weed i did this with cigars
i don't i did this with sugar and [ __ ]
food i don't need another thing that
eventually i'm gonna have to quit
so i just walked away and now i've just
decided
that it's gonna be like
something that uh maybe once or twice a
year i'm gonna do
like once a year or something me and my
wife go on vacation
and i'll do some mushrooms and i'll
smoke a little weed and then when i come
home that's it
that's it my kids aren't gonna see me
[ __ ] walking around
you know
you know daddy liked his scotch i'm not
gonna be that [ __ ] guy
you know and when my kids ask me well
they could listen to the podcast i'm
gonna be honest with them
you know dad have you ever done that
stuff yeah i didn't it got out of
control and i [ __ ] hated myself and i
did stupid [ __ ]
you know
just let you know if that's what you're
gonna do cause i can't stop you from
doing it
that's what's gonna end up happening
however
you know and i think it was really
important for me to be stoned sober when
i was raising you guys because i didn't
want to miss any of it i love you guys
all right
so there's that
i mean other than that what are you
gonna do um
all right that's 30 minutes okay that's
the podcast here
let me um let me read some uh
advertising here
all right what do we got here oh it's
butcher box everybody you know meal
prepping is difficult butcher box makes
it easy hey take it easy butcher box is
a subscription service that takes the
guesswork out of finding high quality
meat butcher box sources their meat from
partners with the highest standards for
quality no more searching the grocery
store for 100
grass-fed beef free-range organic
chicken wild-caught seafood you don't
know what they're gonna do notice that
grass-fed free-range all of a sudden
you're in the ocean everything gets wild
i'm telling you swimmers
watch out and more
their sourcing decisions are made
holistically keeping the farmer the
planet the animal in your family and
mind every month butcher box ships a
curated selection of high quality meat
right to your home free shipping for the
continental u.s no antibiotics or added
hormones for each box each box contains
between 8 to 14 pounds of meat ladies
depending on the box you choose that's
enough for 24 individual meals packed
fresh and shipped frozen for your
convenience so you can save time on your
next grocery store trip customize your
own box or go with one of theirs either
way you get exactly what you want this
is your chance
to never have to shop for ground beef
again that's right butcher box is giving
new members free ground beef for life
plus get a 10 off coupon sign up at
butcherbox.com
and get two pounds of ground beef free
in every order for the life of your
membership plus a ten dollar off coupon
log on to butcherbox.com slash bur and
claim this
deal all right look who it is everybody
it's bespoke post
this winner upgrade your daily routine
with bespoke post and their new seasonal
lineup of must-have box
of awesome collection bespoke post
partners with small businesses
uh partners with small businesses and
emerging brands new people new kids on
the block
oh oh oh
i'm sorry let me do it
i can't sing
to bring you the most unique goods
every month oh oh oh
no matter what you're you know bad i'd
want to be a backup singer in that band
just so i could stick my finger in my
ear and a mic that wasn't on just to do
that part of it no matter what you're
into box of awesome has covered you
has you covered from winter cocktails to
cozy threads and camping gear essentials
box of awesome has collections for every
part of your life to get started
take the quiz at box of awesome.com your
answers will help them pick the right
box of awesome for you they release new
boxes every month across a ton of
different categories it's free to sign
up and you can skip a month or cancel
any time each box is valued around 70
but you only pay a fraction of that
price plus with each box of awesome
you're supporting a small business i
like that [ __ ] ninety percent of
everything that comes in your box of
awesome is from a small up and coming
brand get 20 off your first box monthly
bucks when you sign up at box of
awesome.com and enter the code bird
check out that's box of awesome dot com
code burr burr for 20 off your first box
box of awesome dot com code bur
all right look who is old faithful
stamps dot com you know you've heard me
talk about stamps.com for christ's sake
they've been sponsoring for the sh on
the show for over nine years now and if
you haven't tried it what the [ __ ] are
you waiting for stamps.com saves you
time money and stress for more than 20
years
stamps.com has been indispensable for
over 1 million businesses stamp stock
comes gives you
access to all the post office and ups
shipping services you need right from
your computer and get discounts you
can't find anywhere else like up to 40
off usps rates at 76 and 76 off ups
whether you're an office sending
invoices a side hustle etsy shop or a
full-blown warehouse shipping out orders
stamp stock problems will make your life
easier all you need is a computer and
standard printer no special supplies or
equipment you're up and running in
minutes printing official postage for
any letter any package anywhere you want
to send stop overpaying for shipping
with stamps.com sign up with the promo
code bird for a special offer that
includes a four-week trial plus free
postage on a digital scale no long-term
commitments or contracts just go to
stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and enter the
code burr b-u-r-r
all right that is the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast enjoy the music picked out by
andrew females
and um
enjoy a bonus episode of another
thursday afternoon just before friday
monday morning podcast from a thursday
in the past all right
have a great weekend your cards
hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
the monday morning podcast
for monday march 10 2014 how you doing
how are you
um
i am in a [ __ ] mood this week and i am
def desperately trying to bring
something positive
all right i've been on the road here for
10 [ __ ] days i was going to do this
thing with versi again but he's still
sleeping
and i got to get this thing up and get
on with my day because i got a two-hour
ride out to uh london ontario tonight
and i got a [ __ ] job to do i'm in the
middle of a [ __ ] eight-day run kid
you know seven days in
then i got montreal tomorrow and then i
got a day off
i got a [ __ ] day off and i'm gonna go
to the bruins canadians game
and um
you know have a great [ __ ] time as
you can hear my voice is uh it's
actually better
it doesn't sound better but it's
actually better it's holding up well
today is the halfway point
of the epic
20-day canadian tour door
yeah yeah yeah
um we're having a great time up here um
probably too much fun um i'm off the
wagon
as of uh last monday uh but you know i
only got [ __ ] up twice this week you
know i got really [ __ ] up about two
nights ago but other than that and uh
i i didn't miss being hungover so for
the most part like last night i had a
beer
two nights before that i had one glass
of wine i mean if you want to call that
if you want to call that ticky tack [ __ ]
drinking all right
you want to sit there with your [ __ ]
toes pointed at each other and your
knees together
right like some [ __ ]
jerk off waiting for a bus and a norman
rockwell painting then then you you do
that
all right i don't count those
okay from what i heard a glass of wine
every day is actually good for your
[ __ ] arteries
hell you hear that
somebody finally committed a crime up
here in canada
what did he do huh
did he put on somebody else's skates oh
sorry about that sorry
i like these people up here everybody
says sorry i say sorry all the time
you know hey this this pancake you made
tastes like a [ __ ]
somebody wiped their ass with it sorry
i'm sorry you didn't you suck at making
a pancake right
um i actually had an apple for breakfast
if you're wondering
i'm trying to stay in shape when i'm up
here
i was kidding who i'm not gonna lie to
you guys i am [ __ ] shot i i've been
just traveling and doing my goddamn act
every [ __ ] night i am so sick of my
goddamn voice which is great because
it's making me say new stuff on stage
and i've been writing
a lot now i'm not saying that i actually
sit down and write what i'm really
saying is i'm just saying different [ __ ]
on stage
and um
you know it's a lot of [ __ ] jokes a lot
of dick jokes but you know i'm getting
through it
it's been uh it's been amazing
absolutely amazing we're on a four day
run here in uh in toronto
and the greater toronto area
uh we started off down in uh
i don't even know what the [ __ ]
hammerville hammerstein i don't know
what it is but their nickname is [ __ ]
hamilton
the nickname is hammertown
stop hammertown
um
it was unbelievable
great [ __ ] showdown there
and then i also found out for a buddy of
mine that around the corner was uh where
that that unreal team canada game was in
1987 when they uh when they beat the
russians gretzky to lemieux
right
you guys rem you guys remember
do you [ __ ] member
um
i died let's see i played a pickup game
of hockey in ottawa that was great me
and versi skated on the frozen canal
we held hands and split a beaver tail
and whispered sweet nothings into one
another's ears
we didn't get a beaver tail but the rest
of it happened all right and i stand by
it
no we uh we did skate on the canal man
it's [ __ ] unbelievable ottawa
underrated
brutally
brutally [ __ ] underrated you want to
surprise your girlfriend
or soon-to-be wife with a honeymoon
she'll never forget
or possibly forgive you for
take her to ottawa everybody
it's a government town did you guys know
that ottawa is the capital of canada
i didn't know that
it's one of those towns everybody's got
the big government job and right around
five everybody takes off and even the
starbucks closes but if you go across
the [ __ ] river
there's a bunch of places to get
yourself a beer
it was a little uh
rink out here
i don't know guys i got i have
absolutely nothing
um i'm too old to be on tour this long
and uh today is the halfway point so i
got another 10 days
and um
another 10 days to go on this last night
i was at a massey hall
for those of you who um
never heard of it um
if your favorite band is ever playing a
show there it's worth taking a trip
unbelievable second i walked out there i
was saying to versi like jesus christ
i'd love to tape a special here
but then i heard um i heard their faces
through the [ __ ] roof of course
you know like i'm the only [ __ ] that
walked in there and said you know what i
think this would look visually it will
look really good on camera
um
but uh yeah it was definitely uh very
humbling to be on that thing because i
kind of looked up some of the history
before i got out there and evidently one
night
miles davis charlie parker
charles mingus and [ __ ] max roach
put on arguably one of the greatest
concerts of all time
louis armstrong played there
i'm not a big rush fan but i guess that
uh all the world's a stage
they filmed there are recorded there
neil young recorded some stuff there and
then old billy redface came in and did
his [ __ ] and dick jokes
i had some guy after the show told me
that he saw george carlin perform there
in the 80s so it was definitely uh
it was pretty awesome
to become
i don't know part of that history there
uh i'm definitely [ __ ] coming back so
here's the deal so at the end of the
show
you know version wants to go see that
[ __ ] movie where somebody's getting
murdered on a plane every 10 minutes and
for some reason they can't figure out
who the [ __ ] doing it
okay and i'm sitting there having this
argument with first going dude i'm not
gonna go see that [ __ ]
and he's like he's like dude it's
[ __ ] liam neeson uh liam neeson
neesom whatever the [ __ ] you say his
name and i'm like i like that guy okay
but
snakes on the plane is snakes on the
plane even if there's no snakes on the
plane you know what i mean
it is what it is
it's [ __ ] stupid
and i know somebody's going to shoot a
gun on the plane
you know
and somehow even if he misses
it i don't know it's just it's [ __ ]
dumb it's as dumb as back in the day
when they had a smoking section
on an airplane remember dice clay's bit
you're in a [ __ ] tube it's the same
thing if you're talking about smoking or
you're talking about a [ __ ] murder
mystery how many goddamn people could
you [ __ ] kill on a plane and you know
somehow
the [ __ ] guy is gonna be able to
climb down into the luggage area
he's gonna pull up some carpet and
there'll be a trapdoor there i must have
flown on 9 000 [ __ ] planes in my life
can somebody please tell me where that
[ __ ] trapdoor is it doesn't exist
it's a separate [ __ ] compartment it
has to be and even if it isn't after 911
i'm sure they [ __ ] welded it shut
right
they always show that in movies somebody
goes down to visit their [ __ ] dog
right and then there's some sweaty
middle eastern looking guy down there
that's what they have now back in the
day with some sweaty russian looking guy
it's whoever the [ __ ] we're at odds with
i mean they're always sweaty and they
need a shave and they're down there and
they have absolutely you know and they
have absolutely no [ __ ] morals
whatsoever
they're always down there in the [ __ ]
luggage
right
and then you got the john mcclane guy
how many [ __ ] guys have been on the
[ __ ] plane
john mcclane did one didn't he
bruce willis has been on the plane
wesley snipes has been on the plane
always bet on black [ __ ] right
you thought that one was the last one
here comes old liam neeson
you know something
[ __ ] [ __ ] movies
on airplanes
[ __ ] all of them they all
you name me one movie that took place on
a [ __ ] airplane that was good
all right and i will immediately block
you on [ __ ] twitter
for actually saying it's a good [ __ ]
movie
okay
you can [ __ ] kill somebody on the
plane but you know what pretty much
everybody's gonna see it
how you gonna do it let's just say you
had some little [ __ ] heart attack
missed like the iceman
remember the iceman they made a movie
about him that guy where he would just
he was sitting there talking about all
the murders he committed
you know talking through his clinch jaw
looked like an old sea captain but he
was a [ __ ] hitman for the mob
he had this miss he said he'd go into
studio 54
and he'd act all swishy and he'd walk up
to a guy hit on him and then he'd spray
him with this miss and like three
seconds later the guy would have a heart
attack let's just say
you had
the [ __ ] iceman cometh
[ __ ] heart attack missed
all right
now
you're in a row with three people where
do you think the best place is to sit if
you want to murder one of the other two
people in your rope i'm guessing the
middle seat okay if i have to put this
air quote caper together
then you take the [ __ ] mist
and i'm gonna [ __ ] i'm gonna give the
guy on the window
a heart attack i'm gonna spray it in him
and that [ __ ] guy is gonna go into
cardiac arrest
all right and do you think the guy
sitting to the right of me or the
[ __ ] lady
to the right of me in the aisle seat is
not gonna notice this person convulsing
all right well let's just say they
[ __ ] drop dead
it's so powerful they just drop dead and
just happen to slump
to the [ __ ] side
now i might be able to get away with
that
all right
but only if that person had already
hadn't already reclined their seat
okay
hadn't already reclined their [ __ ]
seat because when we go you know we
begin our initial descent the [ __ ]
stewardess or the male stewardess
is gonna [ __ ] come over and be like
excuse me sir sir excuse me could you
wake him no i can't wake him because i
[ __ ] sprayed him with a heart attack
missed what i can do is press the button
for him
and put his [ __ ] dead head between
his [ __ ]
rigor mortis legs if you'd like
peter
i don't know why his name is peter all
right now you killed one person what the
[ __ ] you're gonna just start going
around killing people
one person is gonna die every 10 minutes
unless i get a sack of cash in
rhinelander wisconsin by [ __ ] 2 30.
you think the airline would give a [ __ ]
all right
250 million dollar ransom is that what
the [ __ ] you want i mean how much is it
going to cost them to settle out of
court
it's going to cost less than that
because they have all the money
right
i don't like [ __ ] movies
on airplanes and i don't like movies
where people have pointed ears and
nobody [ __ ] addresses it the other
day i'm sitting there with version we're
flipping through the [ __ ] stations
and one of those hobbit movies comes on
and this [ __ ] [ __ ] he's got one of
those let it be 70s haircuts where his
hair is plenty long enough to not show
his [ __ ] pointed ears but for some
reason he's got it scooped around the
back of his ear like he's going to
[ __ ] blow somebody
and i just look at i go look at that
dude's [ __ ] ear
how does the guy with the white beard
not address that like what the [ __ ]
happened to your ear what are you
huh
you're a [ __ ] elf
what does that mean what do you what
does your diet consist of
celery and guinea pigs you [ __ ]
weirdo
get the [ __ ] out of here
is that is that racist am i gonna have
to apologize to elves
jesus christ
[ __ ] goddamn movies with airplanes
you know what i mean please
all right oh please i don't have time
for that sweetheart okay let's get to
some advertising for this week
legalzoom.com everybody
um if the excitement of starting your
business getting your first customer and
finally quitting your job hasn't moved
you to action yet you know what nothing
else will
anyways i that i improv that he said the
person said could be a woman who wrote
this she says here's another great
reason to get started it's national
start your business month
slash get out of your cubicle and start
living for yourself month
slash you can do it
all right that legal zoom
um and legalzoom wants to help you start
your own corporation or llc or file your
dba so you can get up you can get up and
running quickly and easily find out why
more than one million entrepreneurs use
legalzoom to start
down the path of successful business
ownership
this month
this month only take advantage of their
national start your business month
special and get a free three-month trial
of all new quickbooks making it so much
easier to run your new business that's a
hundred and nineteen dollar value
everybody for free when you enter bur
b-u-r-r in the referral box at checkout
that's legalzoom.com promo code burr
legalzoom provides a self-help services
and can connect you with the right
attorney but they are not a law firm
legalzoom promo code burr burr
and the classics uh stamps.com everybody
getting your mailing and shipping done
can seem like a no-win situation going
to the post office takes up valuable
time
um
leasing a postage meter expensive with
multi-year commitments and hidden fees
luckily i happen to know a better way
and that better way has one name
stamps.com everybody stamps.com with
stamps.com buy and print official u.s
postage for any letter or package right
from your desk using your own computer
or printer
even get special postage discounts you
can find at the post you can't find at
the post office plus stamps.com is a
more powerful is more powerful than a
postage meter
faster than a rolling o
stronger than silent e
um at just a fraction of the cost you
can save up to 80 percent compared to
the postage meter and you'll avoid those
time-consuming trips to the post office
i use stamps.com to send out my dvds my
posters and any other crap that i send
it to sell at the end of my show if i
can figure it out well so can you right
now use my last name bur for the sp this
special offer no risk trial plus 110
bonus offer which includes a digital
scale and up to 55 bucks free postage
don't wait go to stamps.com before you
do anything else click on the microphone
at the top of the home page and type in
bur b-u-r-r that's stamps.com enter bur
that was brutal jesus christ that was
even bad for me
um
where the [ __ ] am i and why did that
just pop up
why did that just pop up
all right let's get back to this over
here ov over here all right back to the
podcast so anyways i'm still up here in
canada
oh canada
i'm touring across the provinces
um i've had some people come in i um
from some pretty crazy places uh yukon
territories
somebody told me that there's a theater
up there maybe i'll look into that the
next hour of [ __ ] that i come up
with
the next time i tour canada which i'm
definitely gonna do
um
i had someone flying from brazil
and then i had this couple coming from
kuwait
you know and they're sitting there yeah
we flew all the way in but blah blah
blah
and you know we're going to hang out
here in toronto yada yada and i said
wait a minute
i go
could i do a show in kuwait they're like
absolutely
and i said i can say
what i said here tonight in kuwait
and the guy goes yeah and then the woman
goes well
[Music]
[Laughter]
but um
just meeting those two i want to go
there you know
there was some cosmopolitan
[ __ ]
i really would like to go to the middle
east and not get kidnapped if you're in
the middle east and you know where a
[ __ ] freckled white boy
from the u.s can go
you know i would like to i want that
middle ground i want to go to a place
where i'm not going to get abducted by
people who [ __ ] hate my government
and i also want to i don't want to go to
a place that subsists because there's a
tent city right outside the city limits
and people are living uh you know on dog
food you got a middle ground that i can
go to
you know or i can do some [ __ ] shows
out there i can tell my jokes and i
don't have to worry about the shah or
the [ __ ] prime minister
or the [ __ ] son of the king of the
arabs are going to come in and take me
away i don't want that to happen i'd
like to go over there
right
i want to go on wearing one of those
cool ass [ __ ] things
on my head with the little uh
aerobic
bandana
i do that i do that in a [ __ ] second
looking like a cornerback at the end of
the game with my [ __ ] do-rag on let
me know
i'll go over there
i'll [ __ ] do it um oh hey there's a
rumor
i heard a rumor
jesus christ who was that who sang that
[ __ ] song wasn't spando ballet i
heard a rumor
there was a z in it i'm calling that
there was a z in their name for some
reason
it was like three [ __ ] chicks
and they were all almost good-looking
you know what i'm talking about
um i heard a rumor
lyrics
bananarama
you [ __ ] why did i think there
was a z in it
well you know what the fact that there
wasn't a z in it and the fact that i
looked the way i do
and i actually said that they were only
kind of good-looking as punishment i now
have to go to lyrics.com and sing as
much as this as i can remember
i don't remember it
uh who needs a friend who never shows
i'll tell you what you want to know
i could have saved a broken heart
if i found out long ago i don't remember
i was like i heard a rumor
ooh ooh i've heard of root that's
actually written on paper i heard a
rumor o o h o o h
i heard a rumor
they say you got a broken then you know
what now you guys are getting punished
this isn't this isn't a punishment you
guys know i like this thing even though
i can't do you know some [ __ ] wrote me
one time who was telling me how much i
suck at singing like i don't realize
that like that isn't the joke
but you know something
for those of you people who are about to
embark on any sort of a a
a dream
and it involves you having a website
or a twitter account facebook or
anything
um
anywhere where people can give you
feedback just know that people will find
[ __ ] something to [ __ ] about do you
know what somebody said
somebody sent me a [ __ ]
email or a twitter thing i can't
remember what it might have been the
most nitpicky thing anybody has ever
said
when i was down in uh
hammerville there
hammerstein why can't i remember the
[ __ ] name
hamilton
when i was down there
you know at wired of wire i had a
[ __ ] great show go [ __ ] yourself i
killed it thank you for coming out i
went out
i [ __ ] took pictures with people
i'm selling what's left of my dvds the
last time i'm selling a dvd because it's
one step ahead of the [ __ ] laser disc
i got to get him out of my garage thank
you to everybody who bought one
um
somebody actually said great show but
jesus christ your wallet is way too big
can you [ __ ] believe that
how the [ __ ] did you even see it
i maybe have my back to the crowd for
[ __ ] two minutes
in an hour and 15 minutes set and it
bothered you how big my [ __ ] wallet
was
it's not my fault it's stuffed with
[ __ ] business cards
people give them to me when i'm on tour
hey if you're ever here
[ __ ] this is this thing if you'd ever
like some of this here's this thing i
just stuff them in my wallet and then
when i come home i stick them with all
the other business cards that i'm never
gonna look at
okay and when you're in the middle of a
20-day tour yeah it can get a little bit
big all right why don't you stop staring
at my [ __ ] ass you weirdo in the
middle of my show
you ever think maybe that it's it's
it's so fat because it's stuffed
with the plastic money that i've made up
here do you know canadian currency is is
uh
their greenbacks their dollars
are they're made out of plastic now
very smooth plastic and i [ __ ] love
it their money is the [ __ ]
i've always loved american money the
best because that's the money that i
grew up with and i just think it looks
cool
and i like all the weird [ __ ] they're
doing with it with the extra big [ __ ]
heads
they got a little off to the side little
nod to hip hop you know
don't wear your hat like donnie baseball
anymore you got to do [ __ ] the jay-z
thing or it's off to the side just a
little bit
you know
um
oh my goodness what the [ __ ] am i
talking about yeah but the only thing
that stinks about their money is i guess
you can't stack it
there's something about it because it's
plastic it just sort of slides down to
the side
but uh but anyways that was the nitpick
[ __ ] of the week evidently my wallet
was too big
you know i really like that stand-up
comedian's act he was really funny but i
gotta tell you
the size of his billfold just really
ruined it for me
you know what sir or ma'am whoever the
[ __ ] wrote me that i gotta tell you you
have the you have a future as a critic
you really do because
even when critics
like something they they find something
to [ __ ] complain about
you know
even if they like your show like my show
even a good review if you read it it
would be like the big headed
freckled [ __ ]
took command of the stage for an amazing
performance of stand-up
as i watched his distractingly alabaster
hands
motion through brilliant bit after that
that's what they do they're
complimenting you while insulting the
[ __ ] out of how the [ __ ] you look
you know i don't like when they do that
you can you know i'm going to criticize
critics
there's another thing i don't like i
don't like when [ __ ] critics do that
or they're writing an article on a
celebrity and they do that thing where
they [ __ ] uh
they they always got to talk about what
the [ __ ] they're reading because i guess
they always
interview these movie stars
in uh
in restaurants and they always got to
sit say
as he [ __ ] bites into a
uh pan-seared
salmon encrusted pork chop
an older and wiser little fella from the
[ __ ]
angry king show there on hbo
with this tailored [ __ ] suit
i don't know
he has a sadness in his eyes as he bites
into a cherry tomato i really [ __ ]
hate that
i just feel like they're just they're
just building up they're just
like how many [ __ ] words do i gotta
write about this little fella here
ah
with that dumb [ __ ] look on his face
i'm really sick of that [ __ ]
i'm just sick of the look on that guy's
[ __ ] face it's it's i don't know what
it is
it's bad enough when a regular-sized guy
has that look on his face like he's
going to come over there slap the taste
out of your mouth okay i don't need some
little fella
sitting there with his little suit
staring at me
like i said something about him
i didn't say anything about you okay
so you know why don't you get your
[ __ ] fur bra
and point it another direction and [ __ ]
you and your cherry tomatoes what do you
think about that huh
now get out of my face
before i tip you over
[Music]
i'm sorry i really am in a [ __ ] mood
and this hap has nothing to do
with the little fellow on the angry king
show on hbo it really has to do with the
fact
that uh i miss my wife and my dog i miss
my truck i miss all of that [ __ ] while
simultaneously having one of the
greatest [ __ ] tours i've ever had
me and verzi are having so much [ __ ]
fun up here versi started doing this
[ __ ] rodney dangerfield
impression
so that's all we've been doing up here
all we've been doing up here
is it will just be sitting there
you know drinking a beer
and you just go you know this is a good
beer well jay last week i had a rough
one
and i don't know why it's always
it's just been funny
the whole [ __ ] week to us
i've skated almost every goddamn day
these [ __ ] you know what's great
about canada because they're so far
north they have to embrace the winner
and there's just [ __ ] to do
they got like i like looked up free
public skating here in toronto and you
would have thought i looked up a
starbucks the amount of [ __ ] hits i
got on my phone it's just [ __ ]
tremendous so
you know
it's only so long that i can go on a
goddamn treadmill
you know and with just because you have
the option of just stepping off the
[ __ ] thing that's why i love my dog i
love taking her on a hike going a
[ __ ] hike
you know
listen to some songs and i i'm good or
you're out here
and you [ __ ] go out you just go
skating it's fun it's a [ __ ] good
time
oh you know what i did i got a friend of
mine that lives up here and he's an
assistant coach on uh
on a hockey team he's got a son in a 10
to 11 year old group and i went to this
rink
they had four ranks there all these
different games and i have to [ __ ]
tell you something
i've never seen kids of that age play
the game the way these kids were playing
they were [ __ ] it was an unbelievably
entertaining game it was one nothing one
one two one two two and then three two
and then they pulled ahead they got the
dagger got the fourth goal
and these [ __ ] kids up here
at age 10 to 11 the level with which
they were playing this game it wasn't
even the kid with the puck it was what
the kids were doing away from the puck
how they knew where to be
there was a [ __ ] kid
on the other team
last name kid number four or something i
was like jealous
how well he could skate backwards this
kid was like 10 or 11 years old and the
way he played defense i was actually
watching him learning
it was like i don't know it was like an
nhl game but everybody was 10 or 11.
like the way it was played obviously it
wasn't as fast but
you know when i was watching it live i
mean i couldn't really tell i was
[ __ ] blown away by the talent up here
um and it was a great game and when it
was three to two because the other team
kept tying it up i was actually on the
edge of my seat
watching a game between 10 and 11 year
olds i mean it's [ __ ] amazing up here
so
um
anyways i did that
how far into the [ __ ] podcast am i uh
jesus i'm limping along this week
29 minutes in
you know what i've been doing with
bersie this week this is [ __ ] i've
toured with versi for so [ __ ] long
we're like an old married couple
i've never seen anybody who hates the
morning as much as he does so this whole
[ __ ] tour i've never woken him up
with a text because i always do that
[ __ ] i'll text him hey you want to get
breakfast
and he's never quite awake
so i just i just wait till he [ __ ]
wakes up and that that [ __ ] guy if
you don't text him he will he'll sleep
till like one in the afternoon
and he still has the nerve to come
downstairs looking a little groggy he
always comes down like dude hungry
how great was that mattress man [ __ ]
epic that mattress was epic everything's
epic to him
um
i don't know so uh that's why i'm doing
the podcast with donna next week we'll
we'll wrap up the tour we will wrap up
the tour uh me and him will do the uh
the podcast together um
but uh oh i gotta do another one i heard
a rumor
allegedly
there are dates in the works
with three of my best friends in comedy
quite possibly
i've heard rumors that they might be
doing a tour a club tour
starting out on maybe starting out on
the west coast possibly maybe starting
in la
possibly with yours truly hosting the
show
i've heard this [ __ ] rumor
that possibly
rose bowl tailgate legends
jason lawhead
joe bartnick
all right and dude i called it paul
verzi quite possibly
could be doing a three-man tour of clubs
limited engagements
over the next couple of months sponsored
by the monday morning podcast the first
tour i hope
the first of many tours to be sponsored
by this podcast
um
there are rumors that there are agents
right now working on over the weekend
suit on tie off wiping their brow trying
to put together
some dates
on this tour um quite possibly next week
there might even be an announcement but
right now that is just a rumor but i'll
tell you what isn't a rumor
uh i'm doing a date in nashville on may
16th
and uh it's part of uh vince vaughn's
wild west tour comedy tour
and uh let's see here i just [ __ ]
tweeted about it ah jesus bill what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you
hang on hang on hang on
you go to home no i go to me
right
yeah the wild west comedy festival
wildwestcomedyfestival.com
uh is the website tickets are on sale
now
um
if you follow me on twitter i have their
i have their twitter handle is that what
you say
at wild west cf
as in comedy festival and on facebook
it's facebook.com
backslash wwcf
nashville
as in wild west comedy festival
uh nashville
um
anyhow all right so that's enough for
the goddamn promotions for the week
um all right
just when you think my singing can't get
any worse
how about i try to top that with sound
do you think i can sound more dumb than
is than the level of my awful singing
well i think i can
i've been sort of keeping up on this the
events that are going on over in the
ukraine
and uh with my limited knowledge of
what's going on there now and my limited
knowledge of what's happened there in
the past
um
that ousted [ __ ] president or prime
minister whatever they call him
yanukovych
that guy's a sellout [ __ ]
all right and i'm not trying to stir up
some [ __ ] over there okay
but after what stalin did there in world
war ii
they shouldn't want nothing to do
with russia okay
and the fact that there's russian
sympathizers in the ukraine i don't
[ __ ] get it
why does old vladimir give a [ __ ] about
this yanukovych so much
i actually looked up yanukovych russian
puppet and i got a bunch of hits
so
why can't you let the ukrainians have
their own goddamn country they didn't
like you
so much that they actually overthrew you
there's so much dirty [ __ ] going on over
there i think vladimir putin or whatever
the [ __ ] his name is he said that
uh that that was actually
backed
by uh the us would that be hilarious if
we actually back that if we back that
they overthrew their [ __ ] prime
minister whatever the [ __ ] his name is
yanukovych
anna konokova whatever his [ __ ] name
is right
and then we get to go publicly and be
like hey what are you guys doing russia
leave him alone
stop meddling in their affairs
if we actually did do it i have to
respect old vladie
blatty daddy there that he [ __ ] said
uh
that he called us out on it i think he
called us out on maybe he called
somebody else out on it but i would [ __ ]
knows god knows we you know you know
what we did something over there
here let me tell you it was a rough week
over there in ukraine
um
i don't know just [ __ ] leave him
alone
can't countries just leave other
countries alone but you know i think
that'd be great for this country if we
just [ __ ] pulled all our people back
we just left everybody alone and you
know what all our corporations had to
come back too and we started making
levi's 501 blues again but the button
flies
some z cavalry cheese and we actually
made them here we didn't make children
stone together
you know
why can't we do that again
and then you just legalize weed
everywhere and then you use that as the
export we got everybody [ __ ] high man
and everybody mellows out why can't we
do that
you know why
because everybody hurts no the reason
why you can't do it is because
it's the same reason why the [ __ ] nfl
has that stupid ass [ __ ] dumbass game
in england
every year
all right it's because of the ego
you want to put your stamp you want to
put your [ __ ] mark on something you
want to say that it was here and then i
took it to here
you know no one can just be like hey
we're right here and isn't this a good
place to be you always got what about me
what about my [ __ ] legacy and that's
what that that's what the [ __ ]
the guy from the nfl is doing
all right pete rozelle
is the benchmark you got to somehow try
to outdo him we went pete rozelle and
then peter noon
i think
was the next [ __ ] commissioner and
then you got this guy uh was it rykovich
roger goodell
i don't what the [ __ ] guy his name is
but whatever he's got to somehow outdo
pete rozelle pete roselle brought the
afl and the nfl together monday night
football
the super bowl
so the only way to top that is you
somehow have to try and go [ __ ]
global
so he has that stupid-ass dumbass
[ __ ] game in england every goddamn
year
for what
uh can't you just be happy being
billionaires
or multi-million i would say that about
everything i would say that about the
[ __ ] nhl why can't you just be
multi-millionaires isn't that enough
why do you gotta have the florida
panthers
okay and you know what [ __ ] you if you
live in miami [ __ ] you okay
[ __ ] you you got all that exotic [ __ ]
down there you also have to have a
[ __ ] nhl team go [ __ ] yourself okay
you want to go to a hockey game you get
in your goddamn vw bus and you drive to
a cold city
all right
i for one have had enough
of these [ __ ] winter teams
down in the [ __ ]
south
all right having a winter classic game
win a classic game at dodger stadium
people sitting there in [ __ ] tank
tops
watching ice hockey outside
all right i don't want to get all hippy
on you here but how many porpoises had
to [ __ ] die so they can [ __ ] have
enough goddamn water to make that whole
thing happen
you know a lot of people don't realize
that ice is actually made out of salt
water
okay and salt water is the living
breathing oxygen
that a porpoise has to
inhale through its [ __ ] gills
all right
don't poop porpoise is a mammal
are they and i realize that there's
oxygen in water before you guys actually
take that [ __ ] seriously do porpoises
breathe through a porthole
an orifice at the top of the head
i'm gonna look this up now
that's how you spell porpoise
poor poise
is it a mammal
i spelt mammal with three m's in the
middle did you mean mammal course i
meant mammal porpoise mammal
any of the seven species of toothed
whales distinguishable from dolphins by
their row
by their more compact build
generally smaller in size
maximum length about two meters that's
about
6.6 feet they say and curved blunt
snouts
would spatulate rather than
conical teeth
there's a great word spatulate and
conical i want you guys to use next time
you're getting [ __ ] hammered i want
you to slip both of those words in and
if you can actually use them
that's a great line to say to a woman
you know why i like you
i saw you from across the bar you know
what really attracted me
and she'd be like what and you'd be like
your blunt snap with your spatula rather
than conical teeth
what would you like to drink sweetheart
[Music]
[Laughter]
blunt snout that's a [ __ ] good name
for a band
ladies and gentlemen bro
um all right
let's let's get to some of the [ __ ]
questions this week i'm sorry i i'm just
really [ __ ] the bed here
um did i talk about everything i think i
did oh oh people talking about the
posters wearing my posters relax they're
all on their way uh we still got another
there's still some more coming out this
week overwhelming response
and i got i got one guy in the mail room
trying to send all these [ __ ] out so
uh you'll get them all right and they
are autographed
so relax okay and if you don't get them
i'll give you a [ __ ] money back but
i'm saying don't give up hope all right
hang in there
hang in there stay gold pony boy stay
gold all right baseball season billy
ruth
i grew up loving the game of baseball my
greatest memories hang on a second i
gotta [ __ ] close this window there's
some douche talking
[ __ ] muted
all right hang on all right i grew up
loving the game of baseball my greatest
memories as a child included the smell
of a mitt and the sensation of throwing
a ball hard across an infield i also
grew up an orioles fan ah the [ __ ]
orioles were great when i grew up when i
was growing up they were the [ __ ]
they were already they won in 66 and
they won in 70.
uh they blew it in 79
and then they won in 83. look at that
right off the top of my [ __ ] head but
i can't read out loud
do you know i can do that in almost
every sport i can go back to like the
60s and i could tell you all the [ __ ]
champions
66 the orioles 67
uh the cardinals beat the [ __ ] red
sox 68
the tigers won and then they then they
they were having that [ __ ] thing
while that those riots
and then the the the subsequent white
flight that happened and that city's
never recovered 69 the amazing mets
70 the orioles 71
i think was the pirates and then
clemente died
or did he die in 72
72 73 74 was the a's 75-76 was the reds
77-78 was the yankees 79 was we are
family the pirates 80 phillies
81 was the [ __ ] dodgers
right tommy john
tommy john was on the [ __ ] dodgers
that lost to the yankees in 77-78
81 he turned codes he goes to the
[ __ ] yankees
and what happens the dodgers win and
that's why that surgery is named after
him
82
was the cardinals
and they beat the brewers
83 was the orioles 84 was the tigers 85
was the royals it should have been the
[ __ ] cardinals that they didn't
implode after that awful call at first
base 86 was the mets red sox fans know
that 87 was the twins 88 was [ __ ]
kirk gibson the dodgers i can just keep
going people i can [ __ ] go all
[ __ ] day long i know what you're
thinking you probably think i have in
front of right in front of me well
that's just a compliment 89 was the aids
the roy brothers won it then 90 was the
reds 91 of course was your twins 92 93
that was your your [ __ ] blue jays and
then 94. that's a great trivia year that
was the strike here
and if you listen to [ __ ] pedro
martinez he'll sit there and tell you
you know what the [ __ ] expos were
going to win that year why you asked
because they had a young hymn and randy
johnson
i think tim raines was still there they
had a whole [ __ ] great team there 95
was the braves 96 was the yankees 97 was
the marlins they beat jay lawhead's
indians
98 99 2000 was the [ __ ]
yankees this money starts getting
sketchy for me 2001 was the diamondbacks
2002 i think was the angels
2003 was the marlins
2004 was the red sox 2005 was the white
sox 2006
was the [ __ ] cardinals
was it 2007 was the red sox 2008 was the
phillies 2009 was the yankees 2010 was
the giants then i don't [ __ ] know
2011
all right 2013 was us
the giants want another one in there
didn't they we'll say 2012.
and i'll say 2011 was the cardinals
oh my god if you don't like sports
you're in trouble now let's go do
football
i could do it i can do hockey if you
want
i can go all the way back
to about 1966
i believe
right canadians
maple leafs canadians canadians bruins
canadians
bruins
canadians
flyers flyers canadians canadians
canadians canadians
islanders islanders islanders and
islanders
[ __ ] edmonton edmonton canadians
edmonton edmonton
calgary
edmonton
91 92 was that pittsburgh
93 was [ __ ]
montreal 94
was the rangers
95 was the devils
96 was the avalanche 97 98 was a [ __ ]
red wings
99 was a dallas star why are you guys
listening to this
2000 was the [ __ ] avalanche no it was
a devil's 2001 rape work avalanche
2002 [ __ ] devils 2003 [ __ ]
red wings maybe
lightning
strike
ducks hurricanes
all right sorry i'm back let's read this
thing here um i also grew up an orioles
fan too that was [ __ ] add textbook
right there i love the orioles and i
love major league baseball but why can't
i get the baseball
get into the baseball season it has
nothing to do with my team
oh i read that wrong but why can't i get
into the baseball season it has nothing
to do with my team
i was happy for the socks but it's just
hard to get excited about the sport and
i desperately want to is there a greater
reason
i'm missing
uh
well i mean it kind of sucks that
there's no salary cap
and that you know
the red sox can afford to spend a buck
80 a year and the [ __ ] yankees spend
like 220 a year
um
so i mean essentially between the two of
them
saying on a second i mean one of us is
going to win the [ __ ] division
probably 80 of the time
i mean if you go back to 1996
the first time the yankees won the
division
all right and that wasn't because they
spent money that was because george
steinbrenner got suspended
and he wasn't allowed to [ __ ] meddle
and he i swear to god he would he
wouldn't have traded away jeter
um
definitely would have teared away bernie
williams probably jorge pasada and i bet
even mariano rivera just because nobody
knew
he hadn't developed that cut fastball
yet
no he probably he'd probably keep like
two of them pick two of them he'd
definitely get rid of andy pettit he
[ __ ] was up that guy's ass even when
he was crushing it
um
but anyways i don't know somewhere
around 98.99 it's just it's just become
like ridiculously
all about money and i would say from
there on
if the red sox didn't win it the yankees
won it did
maybe tampa bay win it one year
i can tell you right now the orioles
haven't [ __ ] won it since
i don't know when
the 80s maybe
early 90s i have no [ __ ] idea i would
say that that's kind of what makes it
suck
i don't understand why all leagues
aren't run like the like nfl football
where green bay wisconsin
can compete with new york city
it's great it's a great thing so i would
say that maybe that's why you can't get
into the regular seasons because a lot
of times by june what's the [ __ ]
point
um
and the great thing about the orioles i
mean you guys had that that great
tradition there
um
you know when in three world series
essentially in my lifetime i was born in
68 so i don't remember 66 or 70 but i
remember 83 i just remember you had all
those great pictures when i was growing
up frank tanana jim palmer
um
ah [ __ ] there was another one you guys
always had you had like three number
ones in your starting rotation you guys
were brutal
eddie murray at first base [ __ ]
i don't can't remember the other names
who the [ __ ] knows but it was great it
was great to watch
the catcher was hilarious why do i think
it's doug de sensei wasn't any play
third base for the [ __ ] angels
um that's probably why you can't get
into it
you probably can't get into it because
it's not a level playing field it's uh
um i don't know i don't know what to
tell you
sorry
just sort of [ __ ]
spaced halfway through that all right
childhood crushes
billy suave
uh when you were growing up in the late
70s what celebrity ass would you have
banged if you had the choice well i mean
i was [ __ ] like six years old so
was i was i supposed to take out my
little schmeckle
as the jewish people say um
[Music]
i don't know what i would have done with
it
um a charlie's angel or perhaps stevie
nicks
who were you into and was there someone
that everyone was into that you couldn't
understand why
um oh man i [ __ ] i loved everybody i
loved all three charlie's angels
i probably liked farrah fawcett
she's the one i wanted to bang kate
jackson was the one i wanted to marry
and uh i liked i liked kate jackson when
she was on the rookies i mean she was a
[ __ ] nurse she was married to mike
danko
what a [ __ ] name huh mike danko
she had that great voice
ah man she was beautiful and uh you know
jacqueline smith come on
jacqueline smith she had the same
haircut as far a faucet except it was a
brunette i've always liked brunettes um
so i liked all of them
and then i liked
christy mcnichol
much to her chagrin
uh
who else
i [ __ ] liked them all trying to think
of another show i used to watch
i liked marsha brady you know when she
got a little bit older was wearing those
[ __ ] mini skirts
um
even jan in a couple episodes she
hoarded up pretty good for a young me i
like that
um
joanie from happy days when she got
older
you know
was taking a few from scott bale i liked
her then
let's see welcome back carter that was a
bunch of dudes
except for his wife i wasn't into her
though
uh what else
what else did i used to watch welcome
back
this one you know you watched it a lot
when you could actually sing the second
verse
you always could spot a friend but
welcome back
to that something and something but a
better boo
all right i only could sing the first
[ __ ] line um
was that it
i think that was it i had a very
sheltered childhood there was only like
three channels
um
i wasn't a big radio guy i was too
[ __ ] young like i i the only reason
why i knew about kiss was a couple of my
friends had older brothers
and one of my friends was really good at
drawing and he would draw
you know all the kiss characters and i
had no [ __ ] idea and my parents
didn't take me to see star wars i had no
[ __ ] idea
so i had no no crush on princess leia
i remember that [ __ ] that [ __ ] came out
over the summer and i i didn't even hear
about it
i went outside and i played baseball
every [ __ ] day or i went down to the
pool and i went swimming
no we weren't even members of the pool
at that point they had like a community
pool
slash piss tank that we were
that we were members of
yeah i just went outside and i played
every day
go outside and play went out we rode
bikes
played baseball
we did what kids did back then and
that's why we weren't fat kids we
[ __ ] went outside
well there you go i would say yeah the
charlie's angels
i wasn't into to the bionic woman
i didn't get into her
god damn it i thought there was way more
than that
i know there was i just can't remember
anymore
um but was there anybody who everybody
was into when i couldn't understand it
uh no
no i couldn't
i thought they were all [ __ ]
beautiful
i really did [ __ ] women in the late
70s they were [ __ ] gorgeous cheryl
teagues
i don't [ __ ] remember they were all
gorgeous i remember every magazine cover
there was a woman on the cover you know
i was a little kid he had a crush on her
um childhood crushes right i just read
that one uh instruments
bill i'm 14 years old i suspect i'm one
of your younger listeners
i'm growing to learn how to play a new
ins oh i'm going to learn how to play uh
a new instrument this year i already
play piano and love the progressive
nature of drums but i also want to be
able to shred a solo any suggestions to
which would be better to start
definitely stick with piano
all right
they're they're they're more [ __ ]
pianos sitting around than anything else
okay so your whole life if you can just
sit down and just start playing a piano
women will come over to your piano all
right like flies to a moth to a light
that's a great one
to learn how to play so definitely don't
even tommy lee said i wish i stuck with
it
um
you got to stick with the piano uh
i'm obviously prejudiced to drums drums
of the [ __ ]
uh um but if you shred a solo
i don't know
you know what maybe guitar
guitar and drums are great those are
both badass instruments and piano like i
said is this very a social thing
your whole life you'll be able to sit
down
all right attract women
and then when you become married and you
become a father you can sit around
playing the you know
oh you know thatcher and dancer and
prancer oh mike he's playing the piano
gather round children comment and cupid
donner and blitzen
you know you can do your own little
jazzy version but do you rico
um
yeah but either way i'm
good on you for learning an instrument
you know and not becoming a dj even
though that's now acknowledged as a uh
an instrument
you want to be able to actually [ __ ]
do it i don't give a [ __ ] those djs are
amazing that they can
take little sounds and make it into a
song but at the end of the [ __ ] day
you know they're cutting and splicing
they're more like editing an album
while creating it at the same time which
i'm not gonna lie to is very impressive
all right
but there's nothing cooler than actually
being able to play the sounds
that those mouse head people are [ __ ]
sticking together wouldn't you agree
um
yeah drums are cool as [ __ ]
i don't know what to tell you but you
already played piano man so you got that
ear yeah guitar i would try i'd try them
out but don't give up playing the piano
man that's a great one
it's a great one to play unless you're
in a heavy metal band and they're all
[ __ ] rocking out and you're sitting
there with the keyboard that's a tough
one that was always a tough one it's
always a tough one to try to [ __ ]
headbang when you're behind
behind a [ __ ] keyboard
oh we're halfway there
right
those guys in journey
i'd actually like to learn how to play
the piano
you know but i just have too much
sympathy for my wife i wouldn't do it
hey let me tell you
i can play drums with piano i'll tell
you that's a little rough
um
boyfriend cheated
oh wait before we get into this let me
uh let me read the last advertisement
here for the week um e-voice everybody
you are a business owner but automated
phone systems and secretaries aren't in
your budget just yet and juggling
incoming calls yourself makes it hard to
look like a professional here's
something that will dramatically help
you
help you and make more but here's
something that will dramatically help
you make more money in 2014 e-voice
whether you're a business of one or one
hundred e-voice will help you manage all
of your incoming calls with a toll-free
number dial by name directory and call
routing tools your business will sound
like a million bucks can't take a call
evoice will transcribe the voicemail and
email it to you never be caught off
guard again and with e-voice you can try
it before you buy it right now just for
my listeners you can get a 60-day trial
to e-voice for absolutely free
excuse me go to evoice.com and enter the
promo code bill bill
at the checkout
take charge of your business and make
more money in 2014 go to evoice.com and
enter bill at checkout for your 60-day
free trial that's evoice.com promo code
bill
all right there you go
i realize another reason why i suck so
bad at [ __ ] reading
is because my mind goes to other places
i'm really understanding how my [ __ ]
brain works i literally got halfway
through reading that i started thinking
what pictures am i going to post this
week
from my canadian tour tour tour
um okay boyfriend cheated bill
i'm a 25 year old girl you are a woman
lady
all right don't sell yourself short
you're a woman i found out my boyfriend
was cheating on me the truth is i'm sad
but at the same time i get that we're
not meant to be together forever
can you please suggest a fun way for me
to break up with him
just in a way that makes him feel like
he did something wrong
but also feel
like less of a man if that's possible
love to you india all right um
all right well first of all you know you
don't seem too broken up about it you're
25 years old all right you're in the
prime of your life
um
and you're like well we're not going to
be together anyway so this guy broke up
how can you break up with them
ah jesus you know what women are way
better at this than i am
okay break up in a way that makes them
feel like you did something wrong well i
mean you just say it i'm breaking up
with you because you cheated on me you
piece of [ __ ]
but also make him feel like less of a
man
all right well you know what i'm gonna
put that on you but don't go the usual
hacky ways that women go where they
usually say you didn't satisfy me in bed
you have a little dick
you know
and don't go out and go [ __ ] one of his
friends
because eventually you regret that
that's just another notch on your
[ __ ] bed post unless you really want
to bang one of them
that's a really brutal thing to do that
[ __ ] breaks up their friendship and
you don't give a [ __ ] right
um i don't know what to tell you
what could you do
all right let's see if someone did that
to me
makes you feel like you did something
wrong
and make what would make me feel like
less of a man
why don't you just
break up with them and then i guess you
got to go the hacky route
and just say oh by the way and then just
pointed his dick and just start laughing
hysterically
i don't know maybe he'll come off as a
psycho that way
why don't you get him a cake
oh jesus oh man i almost don't want to
even tell you to [ __ ] do this this is
brutal
i get it
is his birthday coming up if his
birthday is coming up you take him out
to a restaurant
and yet you have them bring a cake over
or maybe have your friends do it because
i don't think the restaurant will do it
and he thinks it's a birthday cake
all right
and it says
in frosting
um
you cheated on me
you piece of [ __ ] okay and then you have
your friends if they can sing
and
they'll just sing the happy birthday
song with new lyrics
why did you cheat on me you douche
why did you cheat on me you douche
why did you cheat on me you douchebag
why did you cheat on me
[ __ ]
and he's got a big [ __ ] candle shaped
like a dick
maybe funny if it's more of a limp dick
i don't know maybe something like that
hey look i tried what do you want from
me okay hey what's that hill that's kind
of rough
um
anyways
ah [ __ ] um all right so tonight i am i
want to thank first of all i want to
thank everybody uh who's been coming out
to my shows this this towards me i know
i sounded kind of crabby and tired today
but uh
i'm having a great time and there's a
public rink down the street
and i want to go skate around and get
the [ __ ] blood going before i drive
out to uh london
ontario tonight i got montreal next and
then i got my day off
where we're going to
the canadiens
and uh bruins game
and then that's the end of the east
coast swing
and then we start our west coast swing
which will be winnipeg
edmonton calgary
uh [ __ ] vancouver and then that
little peninsula out there whatever the
[ __ ] it's called
um
i don't know whatever
dude i am [ __ ] out of it i need i
need i'm gonna go skating and then i'm
gonna take a nap and i'm gonna [ __ ]
kill it tonight
in london that is the game plan i just
threw my hat down you hear that
threw it down
get myself psyched up for the show
tonight that's the podcast for this week
thank you to everybody um
who's come out to my shows up here i
gotta tell you man don't sleep on canada
and come up here during the winter time
it's [ __ ] great if you'd like to
that's it's actually a great way
to learn how to enjoy the winter and
come to canada in the winter you know i
actually talked to somebody and they
they
you know i was saying you know i always
wanted to [ __ ] build a rink in my
backyard for my kids that i don't have
and um
this guy was like oh yeah i did it you
know they all had these different
techniques on how to make the ice
perfect
and they build these little ass [ __ ]
rings for their kids
and then tear them down and reassemble
them every [ __ ] year
it's uh they're they're amazing people
man really fun people up here and great
goddamn food the only thing that i'm
gonna [ __ ] about is in toronto
we're sitting there we bought these
cuban cigars and there's no [ __ ]
place to smoke them
standing under heat lamps like [ __ ]
freezing our asses off
trying to smoke these cigars man there's
not one cigar bar
in uh
in all of toronto
and
something sad
i noticed happened up here i finally
went to the elma combo last night
because i wanted to have a drink because
that's where uh stevie ray vaughan and
double trouble have this great live dvd
that they did and i always wanted to go
into it's a great dive uh all these
people have played that [ __ ] you know
the rolling stones did a show there in
like 1977 it's a really famous place
and i went over there and it's closed
it's actually for sale
and people are kind of holding their
breath hoping that someone is going to
buy it and refurbish it
and keep the legend going and i took a
picture of it
the melancholy look on my face last
night and uh
i wish i had a chance to go in there but
i'm hoping that someone's gonna buy it
and keep it going because i i i was one
that was on my bucket list and i [ __ ]
blew it last time i was here i could
have gone in there and i just got too
[ __ ] busy
i blew it anyways that's the podcast for
this week uh go [ __ ] yourselves
i will talk to you next week i'll let
you know about the rest of the tour
and the upcoming possibly joe bartnick
jason lawhead paul verzi it's just a
rumor but would i bring it up if
you